um this is from seraphis who wants to
know once song of ice and fire is
finished
and that weight is lifted off your
shoulders uh what are you looking
forward to the most a new writing
project branching out into other media
or perhaps some well-deserved time
off from writing you know i when i take
time off for writing it's like a couple
weeks
i can't imagine ever retiring you know
uh
even as long as my mind is still working
i i've always made up stories all i
think always make up stories
i have dozens of other stories
unconnected with ice and fire that i
want to tell
um which ones will i tell by the time
ice and fire is finished i have no idea
whichever one i really want to tell at
that date and that's
going to be you know five seven ten
years in the future and i'll be a
different person by then i'll probably
have
100 ideas between now and then that i
haven't even thought of now so
who knows yeah but i will write
something else i will always continue i
think to uh to keep writing
um it may be stuff that the fire fans
won't like
because it won't be ice and fire and
maybe even
like short stories i wrote i began my
career by writing a lot of short stories
i love the short story form i don't
write it much anymore
it doesn't pay very much um
but it's still a great form and and uh
you know by the time i finish ice and
fire which
given the success of it has has left me
pretty well off financially so i don't
think i'm going to have to worry about
oh my god i took a month and i'm only
going to get a thousand dollars for it
uh i'll be able to afford to do that and
still write so i might
write a bunch of short stories but i
don't know i don't know is it harder for
is the same level difficulty short story
versus like a long
you know like like a novel in the sense
that you know the short story is really
kind of like a sketch you kind of you
have to
convey the idea and kind of get in and
get out is that more challenging in some
aspects or is it easier
they're both hard in different ways i
mean they're different skill sets
but you know you can write a short story
in a in a
white hot heat of uh falling in love
with the idea and the characters and
then
it's over you know you spend a couple
weeks on it i mean i've written short
stories as
in as little as a week um
novels obviously take commitments of at
least a year it's always taken me at
least a year to write a novel and with
ice and fire
you know three years four years five
years so it's a long thing
that's weird because you would change
you personally would change in the time
a period of time that you're writing
something so do you
do you get two or three years in like
300 pages in
and then you're like i hate this now or
like you're different or you don't
believe some of the things you wrote
anymore
but that is an issue i mean
years ago i was in when i lived in
chicago i was in a writing group with
gene wolfe
brilliant writer and jean
in our writers group we were seeing the
early drafts of uh
what began as a novella and ultimately
became
gene's famous four book trilogy uh the
shadow of the torture
and its uh sequels uh shadow twitter
claw conciliator
you know citadel the authoric etc um
gene was a full-time magazine editor for
plant engineering magazine
uh that's what how he supported himself
and his family
um he wrote weekends he wrote nights
but the crucial part was he didn't he
didn't have to pay his bills with his
money from writing
so he wrote that entire series before
anyone saw any of it he wrote all four
books
oh wow um in first draft and then when
he finished them
by the time he finished book four he
knew exactly where he was going and he
could go back and revise
book one with book four already in mind
and you know
put in some foreshadowing to things that
would happen in book three that he
hadn't been thinking when he wrote book
one
take out some things that turned out to
be dead ends that never led to anywhere
or whatever
and produce that and that's the ideal
way to write a long series
is to write the entire thing and then
submit it only when it's done but of
course i would have starved to death if
i'd done that thing because my writing
is my only source of income and you know
around if if since i started this in 91
and i'm still working on it all these
years later i would have had no income
for
you know 25 years here so uh that would
have been difficult for me
um but artistically that's the ideal way
to go about it
are there things that you look back with
the original game of thrones and you're
like [ __ ] i
i wish i hadn't done that yeah
tara
maybe a change in that when it came to
the series like it's like you know what
i kind of there's a thing that i
would have liked to do do you mind doing
that for the series
well i've thrown a few things like that
at david and dan from time to time
but i hesitate to mess with it too much
because you know it is what it is i
publish the books it's too late to say
i know some writers go back and they
revise their earlier books
you know arthur c clarke published his
first novel against the fallen knight
and then he went back
later and rewrote it as the city in the
stars both interesting books it's
interesting to look at them and see the
differences
i actually prefer the earlier book
however yeah i'd like against fold night
better than the city and the stars so
um sometimes
your first instinct is your right
instinct you hear that george lucas
oh he loves to listen to the podcast
he's really going to take that to heart
i know he didn't hear it no matter how
many times george
quayle wants to know uh essentially his
question is
you've become so accustomed to character
death which can be hard for
your fan you're a fan like to watch you
know like it's basically someone that
they get to know that then all of a
sudden dies and so
emotionally this guy's question sort of
revolves around how
he has he has emotional difficulty now
being attached to characters because he
knows they might die
so his has shifted to the sources of
power behind
the players and was that by design or
incidental or what's your overall take
on
on killing a character
well my overall take is more people
should do it i guess uh
i mean that that's weird that you can't
get attached to characters because you
know what's dying i mean how does he
carry that through into real life and
not get attached to the people around
him because they might die
they will die all of them will die i
hate to tell you guys this but all of
you are gonna die
let's just show the window guys together
we are the champions
that is true you know somehow right now
at comic con 2013 every one of those
people those 150 other people is going
to die
there will come a time when nobody
living will remember comic-con 2013.
possible the times we're having um so we
still form
you know that's part of the wonder of
the human race is uh
uh life and death and
we form these attachments and we lose
people when we find new people and
and you know we live these lives and i
don't know defiance of the darkness that
looms over us all
and winter is coming for every one of us
you should write all that down you write
all that down
that was good you should write that [ __ ]
down
i know stop snapping probably do you get
excited
but i i i
there must be some kind of a weird
thrill in knowing that you've hooked
someone into a character and
like oh just you wait
actually it's hard for me to kill the
characters i mourn the moments as i do
real people but uh even some of the
villains sometimes
as as nasty as they may be and i pref
they perform an important plot function
and
when you lose one it's uh it's hard to
replace them sometimes
but uh you know i'm a reader before i'm
a writer and
they say you write the stories that you
want to read and i think there's an
element of truth to that
and as a reader and as someone who goes
to uh
a lot of movies and television shows
read comic books i
i like things to be unpredictable i i
hate these
things where you know you read the first
chapter you know exactly where the book
is going to go
it's completely predictable and i want
the suspense of
knowing that my characters are risking
things and
so forth so my final question is about
how do you get how do you push past the
wall
you know when you sit down and you know
wall of eyes
when you sit down and you know like i i
need to write today i have to get
through today
but your brain is just sort of on
lockdown do you step away or do you are
you able to mash through it
and how do you do that uh you know
some days i'm able to mash through it
sometimes i'm not um
that's one of the things i mean i work
pretty much every day the only time that
i take awful days are
when i'm traveling and that's a
different sort of work like i'm doing
here
um or you know during nfl
season when i'm watching my football
games on sunday i take old sunday off
but other than that i'm working pretty
much seven days a week but i'm not
always necessarily writing and some days
i do hit the wall and
i'll answer email i mean i'm presently
about 3 000 emails behind and you know
i may come a day where i get the writing
is just not coming very well so
you know okay i'll answer a hundred
emails today and i got a lot of emails
from george today we must not be writing
yeah what's a good one
minions like ty and his associates here
who are trying to take so many emails
and some of the associated things off my
plate
but those things stay piling up on my
plate
what's a good word count for you in a
day where you feel like oh i got a good
or is it
i hit a good story point or is there
like a like a metric of a word count
that you like to hit
if i'm i'm perfectly happy if i'm doing
like four or five pages a day that's a
great day for me
i've had a day uh you know occasional
days where i've written 20 pages that's
probably the record i've ever had in my
entire life but it's only happened like
twice yeah um
and it tends to happen toward the end of
a book you know like on something like
fever dream army and rag where
the end was in sight i was on the last
chapters and suddenly i had some
going downhill and i'm like it's all
falling into place that i'm building
i haven't reached that stage on ice and
fire yet here there's still
so much more to go so uh